5 25 new wednesday morning now we have
the other side of waiting at a green
light remember that email the other day
from viewer stephen wondering why cars
don't just go already when a traffic
light turns green well i suggested those
drivers are probably on their phones
well thank you for quick responses the
chair now recognizes steve who writes
people sitting behind a car that doesn't
go on green don't know what the car in
front of them sees the pedestrian the
wheelchair or bicycle going against the
light or all the cars running the red
light i have seen or avoided many a
collision by being cautious
patient and ignoring the quick draw horn
honkers thank you steve now the chair
recognizes tiffany who says pretty much
the same thing as steve adding maybe we
can address all the crashes from drivers
not stopping at red lights you got it
tiffany now ron hey when you come to a
stoplight and the light turns green you
have to wait because there's always a
late one flying across the opposite
direction i don't want to be t-boned we
have time for one more here's kathleen
at a red light at fort apache and sahara
guy came past me on my right going
through the red light at 60 to 65 miles
an hour if the people with the green
light had pulled right out would have
been a horrible crash for one i always
hesitate and look both ways before i
move on not everyone is on their cell
phone thanks to kathleen ron tiffany and
steve for riding in buckle up drive
carefully please still put down that
phone if there is something driving you
crazy email me traffic eight at
eightnewsnow.com